[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy thursday
yeah we're back baby listen if fortune
favors the bold we see
we see it favoring the point god over
the greek god
maybe the gambling gods will help build
our fortunes
it's nba finals week baby you just
tapped into the group chat live in the
bleacher report app
presented by fanduel my name is cavi
richards
diving into the data every week is aaron
dolan
and bybee like a campaign three is greg
ivory we affectionately call him g-money
let's get it uh tonight is game two of
the suns and bucks in the nba finals
g-money's been giving away jerseys all
playoffs but now that's the finals
we're gonna crank it up a notch tell the
chat with us
greg ivory i saw i
saw how much you all liked the jersey so
we put our heads together
we put our heads together to figure out
something fancy for the finals
we cooked up something special real
special for y'all we're giving away
up to 5 000 dollars
in sneakers money during the finals
and today we're going to give out six
250
sneaker gift cards to put towards
whatever
kicks you guys want i'm giving out three
pairs
right here on the show so stay tuned
make sure you guys stay tapped in
we're giving out another pair on vr
social
we're giving out one on the br app and
we're also going to give out
another pair on br kicks i'm feeling
generous cabbie
i'm feeling generous aaron so i'm gonna
give out
the first pair uh right now
so get in the comments and tell me what
kicks would
you buy right now if you got 250
go get some kicks what kicks would you
buy while you do that
aaron cabby what kicks will you buy
i feel like i would have to buy some
jordans because i've noticed recently
all the celebs are wearing it even with
their suits and kind of just making it
really stylish again it's i mean it's
always stylish but
i feel like especially for females now
it's definitely in style
wait aaron you're only going to buy jays
because like
famous people are wearing js not people
no obviously
they're iconic they are iconic but i was
always i'm so short i thought they would
look huge on me
but now that i'm seeing more females
where they're like all right cool i can
rock them
okay and yourself aaron how many how
many how many pairs of j's do you do you
own
zero current two zero we got yeah we
gotta give you
yeah we gotta we gotta give you uh some
of these give me the 250.
no we gotta give you like six of them uh
like immediately
they're so expensive sure
but they're worth it because they're
classics i saw um kyle kuzma
wearing those puma all pros uh sorry the
clyde
uh clyde fraser puma all pros love those
i love like the white and blue
um that colorway and because it's the
summertime
i i think i'm gonna try to get two i'm
gonna try to squeeze two pairs of kicks
in a 250 gift card
uh i like the i love the kawaii juicy
fruits it's the summer
i need some sneakers that pop give me
the kauai juicy fruits
because i'm also a fun guy you know what
i mean uh g money what
what pair of sneakers would you get if
you had one of those if you gifted
one of those gift cards for yourself
cabbie if
if if i had 250 right now i've been i've
been you know i've been expanding the
shoe game been expanding the shoe game
just a little bit
it's got just picked up some valencies
the other day cabbie not the flex or
anything
but uh but uh
if i was if i was uh if i was gonna go
get some shoes right now i'll go
go grab those easy slides man those easy
slides i need some comfortable shoes
just
walk around in the house wait are you
talking about like the foam runners that
look
like a honeycomb or the actual just
basic slots no no no the basic slides
the basic ones not the honeycomb ones no
i love how you want to use that money to
just wear them in your house
you're not even gonna wear them yeah no
no i mean i might wear
might wear them to a pool party if you
know if i'm feeling it
clean the box
do you wear slides with socks
that's a great question kevin that is a
great question
because you're from california you guys
do it differently otherwise
recently recently i i mean it depends on
where i'm going kevi it depends on the
vibe it depends on where i'm going if
i'm going to like the barber shop or
something
i'm going to put on some socks i'm going
to cover up my feet i'm going to cover
up you know
i'm going to cover up my money makers so
uh
you're in vegas you're in vegas right
now you're going to if i'm in vegas if
if i'm in vegas and no no no socks gotta
kind of let it let it
freeze to let it be free you know let
the feet let the feet do their thing
okay but all right here we go here we go
let me give out let me give out this 250
i think i think the comments i think
there's i think they're there
i think they're there uh
let me let me get in here and see who's
deserving of this 250 dollars
i got poo oh photo i got
poo hey 88 go 88 go
says air jordan sp sale he's rocking
with the air jordan sp sale
uh i got the the comments are moving i'm
so sorry guys
that they are moving they're jumping
today uh i got
cal ken senior seven how can senior
seven says those jordan forest he meant
abby he likes those jordan four submits
this next one the next one i'm just i'm
gonna give him the money i'm just gonna
give him one here we go
i'm gonna give it to i got liam
o'connell liam o'connell actually i
don't think i can give it away he said
amy jordan i have no shoe game should we
give it to him kevin i mean
well i mean you should have you're gonna
know where
i'll prepare i mean but you gotta pick
one you gotta
three four fives nines elevens
the the tatums are really dope zion's
got
the zion ones are really dope you got to
be more specific
more specific all right we're going to
get more jam
the spatula i got
i got i got mopar 702 says black cements
jordan 3's black cement jordan 3's
black cement jordan 3 shout out to mopar
702
you are walking away for 250
okay so we have more pairs of shoes to
give away during the show
uh and lots of basketball to just to
discuss so let's get into it
in game one the point god chris paul was
matchup hunting and targeting brook
lopez
and bobby portis and he ate their food
he just he cooked them for 32 points
so we asked you on social and in the app
how many points will cp3 score tonight
against the bucks there is the graphic
gmody what do people have to do to take
home
another pair of kicks cabbie uh
get what i need the people at home
everybody in the comments
get back into the comments that means
type up something get in the comments
and tell me
how many points chris paul is putting up
tonight at the end of the game
we'll dm one person who gets the closest
and hook you up with 250 dollars in
sneaker money aaron
cp3 sitting at 21.5 points
how do you feel about that number
well like cabbie said he scored 32
points in game one he's averaging 19
points per game this postseason
also quickly just wanted to add he also
leads the suns and assists and steals
before this player prop at 21 and a half
i do like the over i doubted him last
game
and although he may not be able to put
up 32 points again because obviously the
bucks
are going to adjust their defense for
game two i think he can hit the over
21 and a half even with partially torn
ligaments in his right hand
chris paul was in his bag knocking down
mid-range
after mid-range after mid-range jumper
it looked like an open run
at the ymca listen like aaron said
milwaukee is going to make adjustments
the guards and the wings are going to
fight over their screens
the bigs are going to have to adjust
their drop coverage and brook lopez is
going to cross these fingers
these fingers these fingers these
fingers toes
in hopes that chris paul will be
a playmaker versus a scorer tonight
uh so i'm gonna take the under at 25 and
a half points
but also lock in a chris paul
double-double i feel i feel good about
that
uh g-money what what predictions are you
seeing in the comments
about chris paul's performance in game
two
cabbie i'm seeing all types of
predictions in the comments my guy
liam liam o'connell the guy that i did
not give the 250
to i'm giving him a hoodie this time i'm
giving him a hoodie just because
his comment went away but just because i
felt like i owed him a hoodie i'm giving
him money shout out to you liam
uh here we go how many points did he say
his comment went away gabby it went away
oh okay
okay yeah it's yeah we'll we'll find it
the comments are jumping bro like i
don't know if you
you're paying attention but they are
jumping i got uh k-a-o-e-n-e i'm not
gonna try to pronounce that but they
said
six rebounds 11 assists love the details
there
love the details there uh i'm gonna
you're walking away with a hoodie jb
doncic jd doncic says i got 22
oh squeaking by the hook got 22. shout
out to dave jd doncic
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
liam liam's back he set the over cabbie
so there it is he said he's taking me
over my guy liam
it's taking me over much love to you
liam
uh one more kevin i got one more in me
i got money man 13. he says hi take this
is devin booker game
so he'll drop the most oh he'll drop the
modest
21 and uh 10 assists so take the under
so he says this is devin's booker game
chris paul's only going to
drop 21 and he's going to have 10
assists shout out to you
moneyman13 uh you guys stay here stay
here because
we have more we have more sneaker money
to give away you guys dropped in the
comments
let us know how many points to see p3
putting up
we're gonna give a pair of kicks after
the game to one winner who is the
closest
but we also got two more to give away
right here in this show so let's keep it
going cabby
real quick before we move on where do
you stand on cpu are you taking the over
you're taking the under 21.5 oh oh how
how could i forget man i was trying to
move i was trying i'm so worried about
giving away these uh
giving away these these shoes and these
hoodies i forgot to give my take i'm
rocking with the over the over here
cabbie
and aaron uh my guy cp3 is on the
mission kevin he is on the mission he's
trying to win this ring
and i think that he's going to elevate
his scoring
because he knows if his if he has an
impact on scoring as well as
you know dishing the ball around getting
the ball to his playmakers
it's just going to make his team that
much better so i'm rocking with the over
and betting on cp3 to show up tonight
he was amazing in that third quarter
dropped 16 points hit all of his
three-pointers
you're right cp3 is on a mission as you
guys already know fanduel is running our
favorite bit
the 3x2 for every game in the nba finals
but tonight we're mixing up a little bit
and we're offering you a chance to bet
the 3x2
parlay so real real simple is will there
be two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes
in the first half will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
of the second half there were 27
three-pointers made in the first in game
one
so we know these teams are volume
shooters here's a look at the odds boost
for the 3x2 parlay
offered by our friends over at fanduel
plus 420
great number uh g-money what do people
need to take home
a pair of sneakers after tonight's game
two
of sons and bucks if you trying to take
away
some sneakers i need you to get in the
comments and tell me if the 3x2
parlay will hit tonight tell me which
players are dropping the tray balls you
guys have to tell me which players
are actually hitting the threes in order
to win
that's 250 dollars in sneaker money
aaron what is your take what are you
leaning with are you leaning with the
yes or the no
well as for the last two shows that
we've done here on the group chat when
cabbie was on vacation i
was saying you just have to take it but
of course now it's parlayed
at plus 420. you're out of your mind if
you think i'm not going to say just take
it
the buck shot 44 from three in game one
much better than the sun's going 11
434 behind the arc but at plus 420 i
feel like again it's just something you
have to take here
aaron when you hit your bets and you and
you know you you're looking at your
phone and they come through
is it a is it like a a tiger woods fist
pump
do you yell out loud big fist pump or do
you just take it in quietly
and just and like enjoy that savor that
moment that's actually such a good
question i feel like i kind of jump up
but i'm not doing the tiger woods thing
i feel like that's a bit much you gotta
really hit like a 12 leg parlay to be
doing that
oh and and evidently g money has hit
some of those because he's got
balenciaga slides
yeah tell me what you're betting no
doubt right
uh listen milwaukee's been dreadful from
shooting
and shooting downtown in the eastern
conference finals
until game seven they hit 17
three-pointers against atlanta in that
final game
oh excuse me um game six excuse me and
then in game one against phoenix they
hit 16 three-pointers
milwaukee is trending in the right
direction and uh
and i believe they're going to continue
in game two so i'm looking at you brooke
lopez
i'm looking at giannis i'm looking at
drew holiday looking at you chris
middleton
to get it started in the first half of
course there'll be adjustments made at
halftime
and in the second half drew holiday
chris middleton
need those buckets and i'm just looking
at milwaukee because
they're a top five three-point shooting
team they were in the regular season
so fellas just hit some shots
like gmoney says just give me two just
give me two in the first half in the
second half
and we good we good good g g-money
who's rocking with our three by two
three by two parley in the comments
cavi i am in the comments i am in the
king of sports
it's going to be crowder it's gonna be
crowder because he has to bounce back
from
he has to bounce back from last game and
of course my man drew holiday
will hit take it to the bank three by
two is the best bet
i need that i need those kicks g money
shout out to you king of sports 21 you
are walking away with the hoodie
love the take love to take riding with
the three by two
i have uh elliott elliott wire 08 says
i think booker will catch fire from
three in the second
but be quiet in the first so uh
yeah it's rocking with devin booker
catching fire but i don't know i don't
think he's
betting the three by two here we go keep
on i'm gonna keep
on moving on and i see
i see uh
i see not zach levine cabbie not zach
levine devin booker will hit the first
one
and chris middleton will hit the second
off a
high ball screen thank you for going
into detail
one more cabbie one more zachary
was that worthy of uh hoodie or or a
pair of sneakers i feel like you're
you're on the verge of giving away a
pair of sneakers right here
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm on
the verge of getting a
i'm on the verge of giving away a pair
of sneakers but
that was not it cabbie i'm actually
looking for who i'm giving these fair
sneakers to
uh i see one more one more
hufflepuff 22. booker with the three
by two alone so that means he says devin
booker is gonna
hit both shots to make this three by two
hit shout out to you hufflepuff
i think that's worthy of the i think
that's worthy of the shoes i was i was
going to go one more but i just
forget it that's where they're the shoes
are you was it hucklebuck sorry what was
that user what was the commenter's name
hufflepuff 22. hufflepuff
puff are you riding with hufflepuff 22
and aaron and
i are you going are you going rogue like
like tom cruise in mission impossible
cabbie is the sky blue
of course i'm riding with you and aaron
and everybody in the audience that's
riding with the three i mean this is the
bet that we created
right here we've recreated this this is
a sunset bet
where this is the bet that's based off
of vibes of course i'm riding with the
three by two we gotta hit today let's go
okay so uh salute to hufflepuff or
scuttlebutt whatever whatever the uh
i'm sorry i'm disrespecting your
username i'm sure it's very personal
but hey so lute you're getting a gift
card for a new pair of kicks
so enjoy those sunset vibes and your new
kicks
um listen it feels like speaking of
sunsets and looking up at the sky it
feels like there's divine intervention
helping the phoenix suns in these nba
playoffs
they played the lakers without anthony
davis then they played the nuggets
without jamal murray then they played
the clippers
without kawhi leonard and now they play
the milwaukee bucks
with giannis but not at a hundred
percent
there are only a few real contenders for
finals mvp
let's take a look at so today we asked
you on social
who's winning the mvp and here's the
board chris
paul is the leader in the clubhouse at
minus 150 he's got
47 of the bet of the vote
to win finals mvp his teammate devin
booker broken nose and all
is at 28 and a half percent of of the
vote
uh d-money uh do you feel the same way
as the audience in this particular vote
cp3 is your guy to win finals mvp
cabbie let me tap in with the audience
first and then i'll tell you how
i feel about this what i need everybody
in the audience to do
is get in the comments tell me who is
winning finals
mvp and also tell me why
the comments are with the best take the
best take is earning themselves 250
dollars
towards whatever kicks they want aaron
give us your take who do you think is
winning the most valuable player
well like cappy bench in cp3s favorite
and the audience thinks he can win it
all clearly i spoke to the director of
trading at fanduel john sheeran
yesterday i asked him if cp3's number
is an overreaction to his game one
performance and he said
from their perspective chris paul plus
155 that's what he opened at
was probably too short of a number ahead
of game one but this was due to the
narrative of cp3
finally potentially being able to win a
ring we expect this line to move out in
favor of chris paul again if the sun's
win game two
personally i can't take cp3 minus 150
right now just based
on the value there but i do think that
he is going to win
most valuable player but i think i'm
gonna bet on this when that line
potentially
moves down oh so are you gonna wait till
milwaukee wins a game or maybe
milwaukee's up 2-1
and then betsy so do you need do you
need plus money in this situation eric
i don't need plus money but i just think
minus 150 is a little high so maybe if
let's say for example the bucks win
tonight that line's going to come back
down to probably maybe like
minus 110 and then you take that ah okay
uh you mentioned narratives and there
are two compelling
hollywood endings at play chris paul
winning a championship after 16 years in
the
in the nba early exits untimely injuries
blown 3-1 leads
i mean he had injured his shoulder this
year against the lakers he hurt his hand
against the clippers
and he's playing at his hall of fame
caliber
in the most important games of his
professional career
and then there's a kid who grew up in
poverty selling trinkets on the streets
of athens greece who overcame cultural
language international barriers to
become an mvp to become
a defensive mvp and potentially a
champion and he like almost blew out his
knee
but ten days ago two weeks ago so those
are the compelling narratives
that are at play with chris paul and
jana santa chacupo i love narratives
so in this case give me the underdog
give me the greek god at plus 500.
there's a lot of value on that and i
think personally that the bucks are
going to turn it around
this is going to be a long series either
bucks in six
i'd love to see bucks in seven i'm
leaning closer to bucks and seven
but i'm taking giannis as the finals mvp
g-money where do you fall
aaron's locking in chris paul at some
point in uh during this series
i got the greek god where are you
leaning for finals of vp
cabbie let me tap in with the people
before i get my pick
i want to see where they're leaning i
got joey and
going with giannis shout out to you joey
you're walking away let's
get it uh jimmy burger is in the
comments who's
on a mission to get his ring cp3 who
balled out game one
cp3 shall i go on he's my guy shout out
to you shimmy burger you walking away
with a hoodie we smith 44
d a wow d
a for finals mvp young is big to grab
2020 and finals and he will do it twice
miss 20 boards by one in game one
deandre ayton will win mvp averaging 22
16 two and two shout out to
wii smith 44. i love that great
yeah i love that cake therefore d
well no we smith 4 4 i am
giving you 250 to buy
whatever kicks you want because of that
take was so
fire that take was fire love to take uh
i'm giving away one i'm giving away one
more hoodie one more hoodie giving away
one more hoodie
uh i got druidroopy69 says
clip all for the sweet state form deal
maybe his brother too so he's going with
chris ball that's super funny
cabbie it this one's interesting this
one this one's interesting
very interesting whenever i see giannis
at plus 500
i have to take a step back i have to
take a step back and gather myself
because that is very enticing
very very enticing but my gut
tells me the sons are going to win the
series so giannis isn't going to win mvp
if his sons win the series
i think that there is a man on a mission
named cp3 who will be the mvp
if the suns win the championship
so i'm going to rock with cv3 and i'm
also going to listen to aaron
you know i'm going to listen to her she
said if they lose
they lose tonight you know the value is
going to go up
you know what i mean the values is going
to go up so you know you guys look
around
search search and get some value but i i
do think if the suns
win the championship cp3 will be the mvp
well the suns are currently leading one
nothing as we know game two is tonight
in that first game
the phoenix's big three combined for 82
points
a really impressive debut for chris paul
devin booker and as that one commenter
said it was a
uh d smith or wii smith uh 22 or
whatever
de'andre aiden was just otherworldly was
was hearkening back to wilt chamberlain
and kareem abdul-jabbar
with that uh prediction oh sorry with
that performance shout out to sun's guy
uh sons and four guy who was bang on in
his prediction
against the denver nuggets here we are
in the finals
and these are the odds for the correct
series score
we're about to make some productions
people gmoney greg ivory what is your
bold prediction that you are making
today in the nba
finals as you see the prices in the menu
right there
as for when will the series end cabbie
before i jump in
before i jump in i gotta talk to the
people first
gotta get their input do you know i am a
man of the people
i am a man of the people so i got to get
their input what i need you guys in the
comments
everybody that's watching what i need
you to do is get in the comments and
tell me
which team is winning the series and how
many
games are they winning like what what's
the series is it going to be 4-1
is it going to be no is it going to be
4-2
is it gonna go seven is it gonna go five
basically explain to me in the comments
uh tell me why tell me why
gotta show the work with this one you
guys gotta put the effort
we want hot takes here we want hot takes
only aaron
what is your prediction which way are
you lady
greg well i have sons and six plus 440 i
see this series
going the distance let's remember the
bucks were down two games
to the brooklyn nets who were one of the
favorites to win the nba finals all
season
bucks ended up winning in game seven so
you know that the bucks have the
capability to come back even if they're
down two games
we also saw giannis play 35 minutes with
20 points 17 rebounds
so he looked much better than i
anticipated in game one
maybe suns in six good value at plus
440. uh so you
so you think phoenix is going to win uh
oh no they're going to win on the road i
was going to say phoenix going to win on
the home court like the tampa bay
lightning did last night on their home
ice but
phoenix uh winning on the road that
would be uh that'd be devastating
for the milwaukee bucks
uh yeah and in that entire i don't know
what they're calling it but
it's like the it's the milwaukee version
of jurassic park
where there are thousands of fans
outside of the stadium
watching on the jumbotron i can't
remember what it's called but it's just
it's the fake jurassic park anyway
i'm usually i'm often loud wrong about
my predictions on the group chat i
remember you just said
the brooklyn that's aaron and i was
wrong about a kd
performance it was like katie over under
30 points and he dropped a 50 piece i
was like katie's not going to score 30
blah blah blah
ug money were absolutely correct you're
like
cab you know you know he's going to go
off because he's the best sport
so i'm quietly going to root for the
milwaukee bucks in seven
because i'm usually loud wrong since
these playoffs have been so
unpredictable
uh with with injuries and upsets
i don't know we might actually see a
sons in four but i'm saying i'm rooting
for milwaukee and seven
uh they're gonna win on the road and
devastate the phoenix fan base
and then that night giannis brooke
drew they're all gonna go out in
scottsdale and order the biggest bottle
of
of don p bigger than the mark cuban
bottle of donkey that he
that he opened up at liv and they are
going to have the best night of their
lives
it's going to be a long series give me
bucks and seven
at uh at plus 550.
g-money will you make the same bold
prediction
boxing seven no absolutely not cabbie
come on man come on absolutely not i'm
actually gonna go
opposite of you here i do think it's
going seven i do agree with you on that
but i do see chris paul devin pucker
my boy d.a and the boys from arizona
taking this one in arizona because the
game seven will be in arizona so
i see this uh i see this one uh going to
phoenix
and seven but cabbie aaron
i'm in the comments man i'm in the
comments and i need takes and i'm
looking for takes
i got d row 305
sons and six chris devin
ayton are on a mission yes they are on
the mission we heard that here today
they are on a mission shout out to you
you are walking away with a hoodie
i got droopy 69 droopy 69
says hot take bucks in seven they didn't
beat the super team of all teams the
nets for nothing
giannis isn't going down easy
he's rocking with you cabbie shout out
to you droopy
shout out to you droopy you were walking
away with
a hoodie uh poet
daddy poet d-a-d-y point d-a-d-y
says sons at four sons and four cp three
and one on our dogs
shout out to poet uh you were walking
away with hoodie
cabbie i think that's it
i don't i don't think we've seen uh a
sweep in the finals since
i want to say tony parker and this and
the spurs
won in uh in 2007 that year that tony
parker won finals of ep
i could be wrong but i think that's the
last time we saw sweet paw against a
young lebron
22 or 23 year old brian gabby
williams no the last time we saw a sweep
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry come on come on
man
hold on come on
cleveland dude it wasn't it wasn't
getting bleeding
if you guys don't know the golden state
warriors the golden state warriors was
the last team this week
i don't know what cabbie i mean shout
out to the spurs but yeah
i don't know if it counts in uh in the
record books but anyway thank you so
much for tapping into the group chat
the nba finals edition of the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
chris paul is the betting favorite to
win finals mvp
but maybe take a couple of games off
maybe wait
until after milwaukee wins a game or two
and then lock it in to get some more
value
as per aaron dolan get on the three by
two parlay
for the first half and the second half
get on fanduel arrive at the group chat
for that 3x2 and if you didn't get any
kicks today from gregor claws
during this show don't worry we're
giving away three more pairs
after the game tonight get on be our
betting get our br kicks
instagram and also getting get into the
sports betting stream
on the app and we will uh dm you if you
win
we'll be back for game four next
wednesday
when we'll be giving away another six
pairs of kicks that's fifteen hundred
dollars
in just free free swag if you wanna
sneaker or hoodies today you will get a
dm
from us so thank you very much for
tapping in
uh and finally alongside aaron dolan and
greg ivory my name is cabbie richards
we are leaving the group chat enjoy game
two everybody peace
[Music]
you